TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for "The Developer Show."
Now this is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
G Suite Developer
Hub is now available.
It provides a single
view of your projects,
helping you create new
automation scripts,
view shared projects, and
check on service statuses.
For more details
and screenshots,
head on over to the post.
Node.js 10 is now available
in beta on App Engine
standard environment, and
it's now the default version
on the flexible environment.
For more about
Node.js on App Engine,
take a look at the post.
We recently open sourced a new
technique for natural language
processing pre-training
called Bidirectional Encoder
Representations from
Transformers, or BERT.
With it, you can train your
own state-of-the-art question
answering system in about 30
minutes on a single Cloud TPU
or in a few hours
on a single GPU.
As usual, the post
goes into some depth
and has a link to the paper.
We recently introduced AdaNet,
a lightweight TensorFlow-based
framework for automatically
learning high-quality models
with minimal expert
intervention.
AdaNet builds on our recent
reinforcement learning
and evolutionary-based
AutoML efforts
to be fast and flexible while
providing learning guarantees.
Definitions, details,
and a link to the GitHub
are all on the post.
The annual conference
on Empirical Methods
and Natural Language Processing
was held last week in Brussels.
Google had a strong presence,
with several of our researchers
presenting on a diverse
set of topics, including
natural language identification,
segmentation, semantic parsing,
and question answering.
For links to these papers
and the new data sets
we shared, head on over to the
post, linked in the description
below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
We rolling?
SPEAKER 1: We're rolling.
SPEAKER 2: We're rolling.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
I should go now?
SPEAKER 2: Wait.
Hold on.
SPEAKER 1: A few [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How about now?
SPEAKER 2: No.
Hold-- OK, go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now is good?
SPEAKER 2: Yes.
Wait.
Now.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.